Yes,
we definitely will.
I think they wouldn't be new collecting
categories that we don't even exist yet
at this moment or that haven't come to
total fruition that are going to become
more and more important.
For instance,
a old portable telephones or old
computers,
uh,
all these objects that we take for
granted that we use in our daily lives
and that we changed nearly every four to
six months.
Uh,
those will become collecting categories
in their own right,
or I,
I mentioned earlier,
Japanese toys and robots.
They will become more and more valuable.
There will be a limited editions by
those artists who are great artists in
their own right.
And so these are markets that are going
to develop and go.
And so
it's this constantly evolving.